several people have said they aren't
able to attend
so we will stick them with the difficult
bills
yeah my plan is to just skim through
these bills
decides which ones somebody wants
wants to work on
and make sure there is somebody assigned
each and every one of them to write a
report on what needs to be done in the
future
so
we'll start at the top with the midwives
uh i sent out a notice that the midwives
board is meeting to write their rules
including their scope of practice
and so i would think that anybody who's
interested in this
should be working with the
um
working with the midwives and planning
on figuring out how they're working out
on their rules
who's interested in working on that bill
don't all speak at one
person
his wife has has
is having some medical issues today so
he couldn't be here you dominate steve
pearson because he's not here
you sure you don't want to save him for
something else
okay so mark allegro
with
it really anybody could work on the on
any of the bills they're interested in
but i want to make sure there's one
person assigned who will
schedule the meetings and be prepared to
write at least a short report on whether
we need more
legislation on this one sounds like a
lot like a subcommittee chairman it
sounds a lot like a subcommittee
chairman yes but
all right so mark
uh 1191 electrical work plumbing and
fuel gas fitting in one and two family
housing
that was my bill
and
[Music]
for a constituent
and the
issue with that one is that
who won who owns the building and what
under what condition does an unlicensed
person
be is is legally working on their own
their own building
um
yes john
this
this is more uh executive
executive committee
executive session
but
this this concerns me because
overall
i wish
that we had some kind of dominion this
exception look i put in a garbage
disposal is that
is that plumbing
change of faucet is that plumbing
nobody's going to take me to jail for it
but it's not legal is it
but if it's your house it is
well
oh
but you should be able to hire a
handyman to do that sort of little uh
on the other hand if the guys or the
here i go if this is on the grounds of
safety it shouldn't matter if it's your
house you got a family in there unless
you're a hermit
okay so i think that that you should be
i'll
since you've heard
the trouble is that i want to
redo the whole darn thing and i don't
know how i can do that why not
i mean seriously one of the things that
that bill included was a rewrite of the
to make sure that the exemption for
homeowners was clear and i think you're
right a d minimus exception for
repl i mean not a new installation
replacement
all right so there we go you can you can
have that one john thanks
anytime
okay judy aaron is going to join us on
312.
1395 i want to take that's on rulemaking
and since
senate bill 358 died
senator carson wants to work over the
summer on this
so
i'll work with her
judy aaron who is a sponsor wants to to
talk to us about it she's in the meeting
across the hall she'll be here when
she's here we can do that
all right
it's 13 12 we're waiting
13.95 i'm taking because
uh
i want to use some of the ideas we
developed on 358
and see if we can come up with something
that's a little less contentious
all right 14 29
licensure from massage establishments
jackie okay
all right well 1429 definitely
because
the subcommittee sort of stalemate i
think what what we
decided in subcommittee was that we
needed to look at
local regulation rather than statewide
okay
all right so how about 1444
medical spas
a jackie also okay because that one the
it looked
to this as i remember the subcommittee
said
it ought to be covered by hhs under
other medical facilities not just
not not particularly old plc
i think on the other massage
uh
right sorry well
you know i think the issue was when the
local place had the authority i think
steve was he that was his subcommittee i
believe that dealt with it so okay yeah
the
salem thought they did and derry thought
they didn't right
i remember
yeah
i'm so sorry michael my mike padmore
is um
has texted me and wants to get involved
with house bill 1444 so we'll have some
medical
um associations involvement with that as
well which was an issue with the bill
excellent okay
i'm not good not good to deny you but
taking practice of both of them
1557. jeff you want to write the report
we don't need to do anything on that
okay
i was going to volunteer on that one too
so
well the governor the governor signed
the other bill so we're we're golden
1557 is goalie he'll just uh
all right
this is going really quickly
so
uh jackie you've got two of the big ones
so you're gonna have to
uh
i'm sure you'll have a lot of help on
those because they're important
i'm counting on it
okay
which one was 15 57 goalie
yeah we had another bill that did most
of it so
1566 the prescription drug affordability
board
madam chair i don't think we need to
work on that because uh the substance of
the bill was passed in senate bill 450.
but if you need someone to write a
report i'll be glad to do so all right i
think you would be perfect
because yes that other bill did pass and
i'm not sure how much overlap there is
all of 15 16 six ended up included in
450.
okay then that'll be an easy one
sounds like you just wrote it yeah
yes
by the way i i plan to schedule an exact
session on these bills
the week of the veto session whenever
that is
since we have at least one bill vetoed
already we'll uh
i'll plan on that
yeah do you know is the speaker planning
to do um what would you call it a summer
ban on work
yes if the this week's calendar already
says there's no travel
in june
in july and august okay so
june is open
so if you if you've got people that want
to work on something
i think you what what you could do is
meet figure out if you need research or
start doing some research and then get
back together
probably late august
and incidentally
brad would you stand up and introduce
yourself
greenland greenland yes um
after the committees of conference our
previous researcher has gone over to
this the safety of ols and he's now a
bill drafter
madam chair yes if i just may let the
committee know i've had the
pleasure of working with brad over in
criminal justice
he is on it
very dependable
okay
all right
body
art yikes thank you and
[Laughter]
that one is also a question of local
control and whether you need
um
what you need in terms of of the of
facility or establishment licensing
not and it's
nothing to do with with the
licensing of the individuals
she's wincing so i think not she's
already got two of the tough ones that
we're going to be working on
anyone interested in that
but seriously if the visage
establishments
isn't that basically the same animal
sort of yeah you know what
um i'll i'll do it okay okay because it
follows suit and i think it won't be as
heavy lift so
i'm trying to burn you but it just seems
unnatural no you're right i mean the
whole there
all three of them have a question of
what
what we need at the state level and what
we need at the local level because i
think
all the people that come in pushing for
this registration are in the
are in cd1 and they're not ignoring the
less dense part of the state
where we don't have the same kind of
issues with the
with these establishments all right
so thank you jackie you're going for
taking that on
you're welcome please uh schedule
so that that was kind of my question so
what's the formal process they'll be
scheduled and noticed uh work sessions
mm-hmm okay yeah
and i would suspect
that you bet i'd suggest you have at
least one in june
that you've named shadow chairman
are we going to use our wrists for the
committees that we've used whoever is
interested can show up
so at the if if you the chair schedules
the first meeting
then
um so
it could be
just
it's conceivable it's the chairman in
all the trades out there
it's conceivable themselves it could be
be brave
looking forward okay
all right
well let's we're also going to be
assigned to a number of study committees
there's
one in senate bill 330 that's
got a look at the opera all the
operations of oplc
including its um
its funding
so we will be needing at least two
people to serve on that committee and
diane i think you're likely to be one of
them
okay yeah
and there may be others
that's the only one that i know that we
seriously supported and pushed
that passed so
okay
oh
i don't see where'd you uh are you
looking for comments when it's 3 30 or
even moving on
2 30 3 30.
i think you just talked about you
stopped i stopped and said that's
it's it's
the senate agreed with us
i haven't i didn't notice that the
governor signed it or not but i can't
see him not
and um
and that has a significant study
committee that we will
that we have to support
um i'm the
other thing is the
water pollution and waste disposal which
was
1000 gallon tank
and
what i think needs to be looked at on
that one is whether or not you
who sets the rules between the building
code and the sewer requirements
you know what's inside and what's
outside
and i'm
i'm not comfortable with letting des
have complete control because i think
the plumbers need to get involved
and
[Music]
was that
yeah well this this case is you know
they find they they
they settled and put in a
gigantic
grease trap but the
the whole idea that the
des rule says thousand gallons minimum
and when you ask rule them about it they
say oh well there's we can make
exceptions but the rules don't say so
so
we could probably go to 1500 if you
wanted to or two 750s if you're looking
for somebody to take that on i'll i'll
do it okay well thank you i think that
would be a good one
i was a little 13 12. set back when
um they had turned around to the
individuals and said well we're willing
to work with you after they already put
it in yeah that was just
yes i'm called for it with that comment
yeah i guess that the challenge will be
if you're gonna
actually
let them make exceptions how do you
write a rule that's going to fit it'll
be sort of objective but also
yes
have enough flexibility yeah okay so
like once it got this far oh okay we're
sorry we'll work with you
after somebody had this redemption to
keep on pursuing it a lot of people
might not have and they just and i'll
talk to judy
that's yeah the intimidation factor i
think is what's not
okay and also i mean they could easily
have said you know a thousand gallons
unless a an alternate is approved by the
department
yes
yeah so i i don't think it was
i don't think the thousand gallon part
was an issue because i don't i'm don't
i don't know for sure but i doubt that
they would approve any septic system
that was smaller than
a thousand gallons this was the grease
trap not the leach field or the septic
tank
just a grease strap the green trap had
to be a thousand gallons yeah that's the
minimum
okay so i have another question though
unrelated to that is there an easy way
to find all the study committees
so because i know sometimes if you you
know you might want to volunteer for one
are you talking about chapter studies
no
there's a page on the house website that
talks about
statutory and study committees but it's
not always as as up to date as as it
ought to be
i would talk to
deborah childs in the speaker's office
because she's his
worker bee on getting people to be on
those committees so she's got a folder
like this
so
she should be able to tell you what the
where they're looking for bodies sounds
like a good test for brad doesn't it
i don't know if they still do but the
clerk's office
used to also chase
studies that demand like a nominee for
an entity
so
i don't know if they do that but that
would be something if
you know like uh something
particularly in your case like education
the other thing you could do on the um
for new ones
is
is do a search on you know
something that
study
do
it's probably in the committee yeah
because sometimes they're packaged in
with other things too yeah but usually
they put a study committee in the uh in
the title
yeah it that would certainly give you a
start for sure
because somehow that seems
unsatisfactory you think that this
clerk's office would have such a list
because they have so many other
resources
here's committees
standing committees
statutory and study committees yes
yes but that at the moment we were busy
passing bills and they aren't
necessarily going to be on that website
yet all right you know by by november
they should be there
right
so
but if you do see if you do see one that
looks interesting
please volunteer
yeah so two years ago i volunteered for
the mushroom harvesting license yeah so
that that was fun
so i mean to volunteer anything that
enticing let the speaker know usually
yeah yeah my first term i volunteered
for
a study committee on sprinklers and um
that's how i got involved in building
codes
i got put on an i.t related one which uh
has never met and doesn't meet i guess
it's just another issue
yeah i guess the chair has to call a
meeting if they never do nothing happens
well i wish to extend the
the clerk's
gratitude for having
only two or
only three committees of conference and
they're all and the ones that
met agreement are both on consent so we
should not have any debates on thursday
and i will say our committee did very
well
well i don't know we had we had two that
reached uh friendly agreement very
quickly and uh one that totally stamina
did but
that's why we're studying uh yeah yeah
that's why which one that's why we're
working on it
which one got stuck i forgot
expansion of japan members oh yeah the
uh
the senate dug there
the uh
it
that one was very annoying
even after we agreed to eczema awareness
month
i mean the biggest issue i think
with ours and i've heard from others is
that
everybody shows up to the house hearings
and expresses their views and we try and
take them into account and then nobody
bothers to show up in front of the
senate
and so for the child care licensing one
i think the only people that showed up
there were from the department
and so they didn't hear about any
problems
[Music]
yeah not sure why the house hearings are
so much easier to get to
all right
anybody have anything else that needs to
be discussed
um i'm just
seeing some folks who took the trouble
to come and i
was wondering if you wanted to hear from
any of them on any of the bills that
they have concerns on
oh thank you
and
okay and you're with des right
ah okay
what's going on
okay
thank you
say hi
hey
representative
okay
yeah
all right well this is
remarkably uh congenial
sorry hello judy
tony decided to take on 1312.
so
we're figuring out what we can do about
that because
we can talk
yeah so
so we've got two that just need a report
and the rest we're actually going to be
working on somehow so
well we're not drafting legislation
draft a report well you could draft
legislation if you like we don't have to
i wouldn't
my output will be criteria for what the
legislation should look like that's
equally important
okay anybody else have anything
well thank you all it's been a marvelous
session
and uh we'll just close up here
you